-Hi, everyone.
Thanks for tuning in.
My name is Jimmy Fallon.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
And hi, Roots.
Nice to see you.
Very nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, hey.
-Quest, you -- you made it --
you made it into the studio
today, which --
-Good. I escaped.
-Yeah.
-What, were you in between
two trees or where --
-I was in between -- I was on
the set of "Jumanji."
That's where I was.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you know -- I mean,
did you get out of your vehicle
and walk home?
-I ran home.
Yes.
-Yeah.
-Trees, power lines,
everything was falling.
Turkeys in the street.
Bears on the corner.
Deer everywhere.
Like --
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yesterday was all --
[ Singing theme ]
-Yeah, it was all crazy, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Well, welcome back.
Thanks for --
Thanks for being here.
I mean, I am happy you're here.
-Well, thank you.
Glad to be here.
-I mean, thankful
but also happy.
-I'm grateful
and thankful that you're happy.
-There you go. Good.
Well, I mean, same goes with
you, Tariq, as well.
-I appreciate that.
-Yeah.
James.
Nice to see you.
-Ooshi, ooshi.
-Ooshi.
Let's get to the news.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some jokes here,
guys.
After the nightmare that was
his interview on HBO,
this morning President Trump
cocooned himself
in the weighted blanket
that is "Fox & Friends."
[ Light laughter ]
That's right.
After several brutal interviews,
Trump called in to
"Fox & Friends" this morning.
He basically tried dating
other shows and then ended up
back with his ex.
"Well, well, well.
Look who came crawling back."
Yep. Trump went on and on this
morning for 53 minutes.
Most Americans were like,
"Hey, if we wanted to hear
the President ramble
about nothing for an hour,
we'd have watched the
coronavirus briefing."
[ Laughter ]
The interview with
"Fox & Friends" went about
how you would expect.
At one point, Trump made a
pretty shocking claim
about how long mail-in
voting could delay the results
of the election.
Listen to this.
-If it doesn't work out,
you're not going to know
the November 3rd
election results.
I'm talking for the country.
It could be for months
and months.
I mean, actually,
it could be for years.
[ Laughter ]
-Months or years?
It's an election, not the
results of a COVID test.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Trump was like,
"It's going to take a while.
Imagine the time it takes me
to walk down a ramp.
Now double that.
[ Laughter ]
I was wearing wooden --
[ Laughs ]
I was wearing wooden soled
shoes, or leather soled.
Brand new, made from wood.
They were wooden.
I was wearing clogs."
[ Laughter ]
At one point, Trump was asked
about schools reopening
and here's what he had
to say.
-My view is the
schools should open.
This thing is going away.
It will go away
like things go away.
And my view is that schools
should be open.
If you look at children,
children are almost --
and I would almost say
definitely --
but almost immune
from this disease.
[ Crew groans ]
-"For example, I've had people
coughing on Don Jr.'s face
for months,
and so far nothing."
At that point, Dr. Birx wrapped
her scarf around her eyes
and just walked into traffic.
She's like, "I --"
Even Brian Kilmeade seems to be
losing faith in Trump,
because after that,
he poured out a Diet Coke
and sang "It's So Hard to Say
Goodbye (To Yesterday)."
It was such a bad answer,
for the rest of the interview,
"Fox & Friends" replaced
all the anchors with this.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, a lot of people are
criticizing the interview,
but Trump was proud of it.
Right after, he held up a chart
showing that the U.S.
leads the world in calls
into morning shows.
[ Light laughter ]
"You can see it right here.
It's very clear."
Later in the interview,
Trump was asked about
his convention speech and where
it will take place.
Listen to what he had to say.
-There are reports
that you're considering
possibly giving your
convention acceptance speech
from the White House lawn.
Well, we're thinking about it.
It would be the easiest
from the standpoint of security.
It's easy. And I think
it's a beautiful setting.
I love the building.
I'm there right now.
I spend a lot of time here.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, Trump was like, "Where
are they going to have it?
At the White House or
Yo-se-Mite National Park."
[ Laughter ]
"Or the banks of
the Mis-pee-pee River."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm still deciding."
That's for you, Robin.
Basically Trump's message is,
"Nobody should worry
about the virus.
Anyway, totally unrelated,
I'll be giving my speech
from home."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile when Trump said it
would be easier for security,
the Secret Service
was like, "Yeah, we're good.
I think we can handle it.
Don't worry about it."
But Trump's not the only one
who's changing
his convention plans.
Watch.
-Breaking news from
the Democratic National
Campaign Committee
announcing that former
Vice President Joe Biden
will not be traveling
to Milwaukee,
a battleground state, Wisconsin,
due to concerns over COVID-19.
Instead, Biden will accept the
nomination from Delaware.
-Right now in Milwaukee, the guy
who just blew up 10,000 balloons
is like, [ High-pitched ]
"Are you fricking kidding me?"
[ Laughter ]
Biden says he wants to speak
in front of Delaware's
most famous landmark,
the sign that says,
"Welcome to Pennsylvania."
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, get this.
In --
[ Laughter ]
Guys, get this,
a new poll found that
four out of five parents have
considered home schooling
their kids this fall.
To hear from the other side,
we're now joined by
one of the parents who hasn't
considered home schooling.
Hey, thanks for joining us.
-Hey.
-So like I said, most parents
are at least thinking
about home schooling
their kids this fall,
but you're not.
-Nope.
-You haven't even
thought about it?
-Nope.
-I mean, if there was a major
outbreak in your area,
you'd consider it,
though, right?
-Nope.
-What if health officials
advised you
to home school your kids?
-Nope.
-Okay, but, let's say schools
are fully closed this fall.
You have no choice but to
home school your kids, right?
-Debatable.
-I mean, you wouldn't just
drop them off in a parking lot
in an empty school.
-Maybe.
-How many kids do you have?
-Seven.
-Wow.
How old are they?
-12.
[ Laughter ]
-All of your kids are 12?
-Yep.
-How many boys?
How many girls?
-Boys.
[ Laughter ]
-All boys?
-Yep.
-So you've been in a house
all summer
with seven 12-year-old boys?
-Yep.
[ Knocking sound ]
Jesus.
[ Knocking ]
-I'm sorry, wait --
-[ Boys shouting ]
-Are you -- are you doing this
interview from your bathroom?
-Yep.
-[ Shouting continues ]
[ Laughter ]
-Is it the only place
you can be alone?
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
[ Knocking continues ]
-Do you work out of there, too?
-Yep.
-What do you do
for a living?
[ Laughter ]
-Air traffic control.
-I'll let you get back
to work then.
The parent who hasn't considered
home schooling, everyone.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-The loop.
Can I just hear
the loop one more time?
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitates knock ]
[ Knocking ]
-Let's get to some
entertainment news.
Guys, earlier today, Disney made
a big announcement.
-After months of delays,
audiences will finally be able
to see Disney's
live action "Mulan" at home.
The remake of the classic is
heading to Disney+
on September 4th
for an additional $30.
-Yeah. "Mulan" will be
on Disney+ for 30 bucks.
That is why when you click
purchase, it says,
"Are you sure?"
Then is says,
"Seriously, are you sure?"
Then, finally, it says,
"Okay, Rockefeller."
[ Laughter ]
30 bucks may seem like a lot,
but remember,
if you took your kid to the
theater, your tickets are $20,
the snacks are $10,
and you haven't even gotten to
the vodka Red Bull
in your hydro flask.
Well, guys, with everything
that's happening,
it's also a big week for
celebrity birthdays.
President Obama,
Billy Bob Thornton,
Tony Bennett,
Arnold Schwarzenegger.
So, we thought it would be fun
to take a break
from all the news
and imagine them
all in a room together just
wishing each other
happy birthday.
Take a look.
-Happy birthday, Billy.
-Happy birthday, Barack.
-Happy birthday, Arnold.
-Happy birthday, Tony.
-Happy b-day, Barack.
-Happy birthday, Billy.
-Happy birthday, Arnold.
-Happy birthday, Tony.
-Happy birthday, Barack.
-Okay.
Happy birthday on three.
One, two, three!
-Happy birthday!
-Where's the cake?
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Tony Bennett ]
"Happy birthday."
[ Laughter ]
That's the best one.
-I know.
-And finally,
this is crazy.
Three men were stranded on a
deserted island in the Pacific,
so they drew a giant "SOS"
on the beach
and it actually worked.
Yep.
They got rescued by a helicopter
after just three days.
Check it out.
See that?
Yeah.
Asked how they survived,
they said,
"Well, let's just say there
used to be four of us."
[ Laughter ]